record high temperatures have prompted
dozens of wildfires in european
countries
in greece crews have been battling large
fires with water bomber planes
and helicopters fires destroyed homes
and farms and prompted evacuations of
populated areas
here's my house you can see i have
nothing left only the clothes i'm
wearing
me and my wife and the child nothing is
left
right now we need help straight away we
have no house
no water no sheep absolutely nothing
an estimated 60 forest fires broke out
in the past 24 hours
most were quickly brought under control
but local weather service is predicting
higher temperatures in the coming days
in areas already experiencing a heat
wave
it was a nightmare last night the
situation was really bad the area was
inaccessible and with strong winds it
was not easy for help to reach the area
the disaster that's happened here is
tremendous before the fire this area was
an exceptional
green lung of the earth in italy
extreme weather brought floods to the
north and fires to cities across the
south
dozens of people have been relocated
from coastal towns
and firefighters on the island of sicily
battled dozens of wildfires there
all this as temperatures continue to
climb zain basravi al-jazeera